Ein einfacher Rhythmus und
eine jahrhundertealte Melodie
verändern alles für Nathan Evans.
„Wellerman“ ist ein sogenanntes Shanty.
Mit dem Seemannslied entert der Schotte
europaweit die Spitze der Musikcharts.
Es ist unglaublich.
Als ob ein Traum wahr geworden wäre
– unfassbar.
Und ich warte die ganze Zeit darauf,
jeden Moment aus
diesem Traum aufzuwachen.
Denn bis vor Kurzem trägt
Nathan Evans in Airdrie,
einer schottischen Stadt
bei Glasgow, noch Briefe aus.
Nebenher singt er Songs nach und lädt sie
auf der Videoplattform TikTok hoch.
Auf Wunsch seiner Follower
covert er auch Shantys.
So wie „Leave her, Johnny“
und andere.
Ende 2020 der Überraschungserfolg:
Seine Version
des neuseeländischen Walfang-Liedes
„Soon May the Wellerman Come“
wird ein viraler Hit.
Ich dachte, ich lade „Wellerman“ hoch,
damit meine Follower und ich Spaß
haben und mitsingen können,
und dann geht’s mit dem
nächsten Lied weiter.
Nie im Leben hätte ich gedacht,
dass es ein Song wird,
der die Charts auf der ganzen Welt stürmt.
Es ist nicht zu fassen.
Er löst eine Welle aus und viele machen mit.
Das Internet wird mit dem
„Wellerman“ geradezu überflutet.
Während der Corona-Pandemie trifft
der Song den Nerv vieler Menschen,
denn das Seemannslied handelt
von der Einsamkeit der Seeleute.
Der Song kommt genau in einer Zeit,
in der alle zu Hause festsitzen,
ausgebrannt sind und
ihre Freunde nicht sehen können.
Jeder kann mitmachen, mitsingen,
mit den Füßen stampfen,
in die Hände klatschen oder
ein Instrument dazu spielen.
Man kann singen oder etwas vorführen,
wenn man will.
Jeder ist dabei, und das zaubert den Leuten
ein Lächeln auf die Lippen.
Für gute Laune sorgten solche Lieder
schon ab dem 15. Jahrhundert,
als Seefahrer monatelang
auf den Meeren unterwegs waren.
In den sogenannten
„Call and Response“-Songs,
also „Ruf und Antwort“-Liedern,
sang der Shantyman eine Strophe vor
und dann stimmte der Rest
der Mannschaft beim Refrain mit ein.
Im digitalen Zeitalter singt die
Internet-Community mit.
Durch die Duett-Funktion bei TikTok
entstehen so mehrstimmige Seemannschöre.
Sogar Prominente wie die
US-Violinistin Lindsey Stirling
oder der britische Gitarrist Brian May
werden vom Shanty-Hype erfasst.
Ich war sprachlos, als ich herausfand,
dass Brian May, Andrew Lloyd Webber,
Ronan Keating und Gary Barlow mitmachen.
All diese Leute zu sehen, wie sie Shantys
singen und sich einbringen,
das ist einfach wunderbar.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass so etwas mal passieren würde.
Mit einem Plattenvertrag in der Tasche
kündigt er seinen Job als Postbote
– und konzentriert sich nun
auf seine Musikkarriere.
Gerade arbeitet er an seinem ersten Album.
Auch eine Tour ist in Planung.
Wenn alles scheitern sollte,
werde ich mir gerne wieder
einen anderen Job suchen
und werde das als Erfahrung mitnehmen.
Und ich werde weiter
Gitarre spielen und singen.
Es macht keinen Unterschied für mich.
Doch nur wer es wagt,
hat eine Chance auf Erfolg.
Seinem Traum,
von der Musik leben zu können,
ist Nathan Evans
einen großen Schritt nähergekommen.